Reisen in diesen Wochen egal ob Herr
Bahn Auto oder Flugzeug es ist kein
Vergnügen Zugausfälle Staus endlose
Warteschlangen sie sind die Regel
inzwischen pünktlich ans Ziel zu kommen
fast unmöglich ein Armutszeugnis für
einen Verkehrsminister der sich genau
darüber definiert
und die Kernaufgabe des
Verkehrsministers ist die Gesellschaft
mobil zu halten und der Logistik und die
Lieferketten stabil zu halten genau
dafür bräuchte es eine funktionierende
Bahn doch das Chaos zur Zeit beispiellos
die Regierung feiert sich zwar für das
Zitat Sommermärchen des 9-euro-tickets
und für das deutschland-ticket ab
nächsten Jahr aber was nützt es wenn die
Kapazitäten dafür nicht ausreichen der
Sanierungsstau immens kurzfristig wird
es keine Besserung geben neu ist und das
unterscheidet Wissing von seinen
Vorgängern von der CSU das künftig ganze
Teilstrecken der Bahn gesperrt und
saniert werden Geld soll es dafür geben
so viel wie nötig
und Bahn haben gerade ein
milliardenschweres Projekt für die
weitere Digitalisierung der Bahn
unterschrieben ein kleiner Schritt
vorwärts
wir wollen so haben wir uns das
vorgenommen mit der Generalsanierung der
Korridore spätestens in 20 30 fertig
sein 20 30 vorläufig also keine
Entwarnung für Bahnreisende parallel
dazu müssen in Deutschland zahlreiche
marode Autobahnbrücken und Straßen
saniert werden Minister Wissing will
auch die Planungsverfahren für
Straßenbauprojekte beschleunigen die
Grünen befürchten damit dem Bau neuer
Autobahn wollen schnellere Verfahren nur
für die Schiene seit Wochen streiten sie
darüber die Aufgabe bei der Bahn ist
riesig zugleich haben wir eins der
dichtesten Straßennetze der Welt das
haben wir jetzt schon da müssen wir
dafür sorgen dass das in Schuss bleibt
oder ein Schuss kommt weil wir auch dort
ein riesigen sanierungssteuer übernommen
haben
wenn man diese beiden Aufgaben ernst
nimmt dann bleibt er nicht mehr für Raum
für irgendwelche Neubau Fantasien
gleichzeitig haben wir natürlich auch in
Bedarf unsere Straßen und vor allen
Dingen Autobahnbrücken zur tüchtigen
denn klar ist wir brauchen Klimaschutz
und wir müssen die Klimaschutzziele
einhalten aber auf dem Weg dorthin
sollten die Regale in den Supermärkten
nicht leer sein die drei
Koalitionspartner sind sehr
unterschiedliche Partner und ich erlebe
das ja am eigenen Leib auch fast jede
Woche ich bin dann schon ab und zu in
der Moderatorenrolle also die beten
sozusagen verkehrspolitischen Ansätze
von Grünen und FDP die passen halt von
Haus aus nie unbedingt zusammen es geht
darum dass Bahnprojekte und
brückenprojekte aus unserer sich früher
oder zu behandeln sind ein weiterer
Streitpunkt in der Ampel das
Verkehrsministerium verfehlt bisher die
gesetzlich vorgeschriebenen
Klimaschutzziele eine Studie der Agora
Verkehrswende legte diese Woche eine
ernüchternde Bilanz vor nach einem Jahr
Ampel Zitat die 12 Monate seit
Regierungsantritt waren ein verlorenes
Jahr für die Klimapolitik im Verkehr ein
Jahr des rasenden Stillstands
Lösungsvorschläge wir müssen alles in
Angriff nehmen also die Elektrifizierung
der Pkw die Elektrifizierung der LKW
unten Verlagerung vom Auto weg auf um
sehr freundlicheren Verkehrsträger also
Bus bahnfahrrad und Fuß es gibt viele
Bereiche in denen es nicht schnell genug
vorangeht auch ein Tempolimit würde zum
Einsparen von CO2 beitragen die FDP
jedoch lehnt Verbote ab die Prämisse ist
klar wir können aber nicht Klimaschutz
betreiben und dafür unsere Mobilität und
unsere Lieferketten Opfern und damit das
in ein vernünftiges Verhältnis kommt
gibt es Ressort Zuständigkeiten die
ideologischen Grabenkämpfe zwischen FDP
und Grünen gehen weiter morgen will das
FDP Präsidium eine
planungsbeschleunigung beim Bau und der
Sanierung von Autobahnen beschließen die
Debatte sei kontraproduktiv heißt es von
den Grünen der Streit über die
Verkehrspolitik er wird anhalten